this is what's known as this fall bard
stroll it's a brisk hands and pockets
type of affair because you're at the end
of the earth and it's really freaking
cold so this is the first time you ever
see this place I've never been here
before no I never even thought I would
ever be in scull bar my Arctic companion
is NAT Friedman CEO of the software
platform ground he usually lives in San
Francisco but he's traveled to the ends
of the earth to do something peculiar so
we're here in Svalbard at 78 degrees
north latitude at the site of the future
github Arctic code vault
he's depositing 6,000 of the most
popular open-source projects in an
archive inside this mountain open the
vault that's goal here is one to protect
the world software from the apocalypse
and to preserve our modern way of life
the man is ambitious how much of this is
an existential risk type thing most of
the time when you build a product you
build it hoping that lots of people use
it all the time and this is probably a
case where we're building a product kind
of hoping that it never gets you that's
a hit away fingers crossed
fingers crossed
[Music]
for those of you who haven't entered in
Svalbard it's located way up here the
frigid barren wasteland void of trees or
any meaningful vegetation the last spot
humans can tolerate before the Arctic
proves too much getting here requires
much planning and deep resolve to face
Mother Nature at our worst or you know a
private jet and the courage gained by
downing bubbly by the gallon and
embracing your inner Playboy hello
[Music]
coal mining used to be the main game
it's fall hard but since that's not cool
anymore people here have had to find
some other uses for all their permafrost
which brings us back to our coal mine
and our code cave is this what you
expected the entrance to your seed vault
so look like it generally looks like the
entrance to a mine so I believe we are
going deep inside a mountain this is old
coal mine
Matt and I were joined by some proper
mind men who taught us the ways of the
mine
okay Oh to check that methane and who
are also helpful in firming up the
concept of existential risk you produce
called devil come a little bit guess you
don't feel it you don't you have epoxy
yeah okay
you thought that sounds dangerous with
the safety brief down it's time to get
on to the real business of protecting
the world's code see you see their
difference this is how it works the data
is stored on a reel of film coated with
iron oxide powder the information can
still be read by a computer or if need
be by a human with a magnifying glass
how long will this last
we've confident for a thousand and we're
aiming now to do a research project to
document mm yes okay two thousand years
you think this could last up to two
thousand years we collected the film
which is spooled inside these white
plastic cases and headed into the
darkness
usually yeah like usually I have the
hard hats and I feel like it's for show
as we venture further into the abyss let
me catch you up on who NAT is that's
company github is the main place people
go to write open source code tens of
millions of people hop on github and
create the applications that make the
world tick which is why not wants to
protect it from terrorist hackers
electromagnetic pulses and other
unforeseen disasters where are we going
and where we were going was not good
okay but like all intrepid explorers we
would not let something like a lack of
oxygen stop us and thank God for that
because I now present to you the most
futuristic ultra secure sci-fi inspired
code vault you will ever see okay it's
basically a tool shed but it's still
cool Wow
into the data vaults I mean this is real
one of the github Arctic code vault and
we're gonna put it here in Svalbard
under the ice for the next 2,000 years I
think 20 years ago if you'd told someone
that you know 20 years in the future in
the year 2020 all of human civilization
will depend on and run on open source
code written for free and put into
almost every product in the world I
think people would say like that's crazy
like that's never gonna happen I think
that software is written by big
professional companies and and yet here
we are and so how much of this is just
making sure we could restore our way of
life I'm overall pretty optimistic about
civilization like I think we can bet
that you know humans will be thriving
for a long time on planet earth and so
another way to think about this is it's
just like a time capsule like there's
this amazing moment in history where the
whole world is starting to run on soft
and that software is made out of
open-source you know the source is sort
of Ian everything 20 years ago
open-source software was seen as a
fringe idea the big companies kept their
code secret holy weird hippie types
shared code and gave it away for free
fast forward to 2019 and about 40
million people in 2 million companies
and organizations use github
that's why Microsoft paid a stunning 7.5
billion dollars to acquire the company
last year safe in the knowledge that
open-source code will be secure it was
time for me to explores fall bard
Matt and I returned to our nerd pursuits
this time we were checking out the
northernmost github users who work at an
observatory dedicated to researching the
Northern Lights it was lunchtime and we
needed to get there quick before it got
dark 1:20 p.m. Sun is setting
it never really rose actually we didn't
see it all day here in this Observatory
perched on a snowy mountain works some
seriously Hardy scientists so during the
daytime for three and a half months over
the winter it is completely dark and so
we can make 24 hour observations of the
aurora why would somebody want to study
the aurora the aurora is important for
understanding the whole process of the
connection between the Sun and the
Earth's magnetic field and then the
ultimate impact on the atmosphere so
this is what we call space weather this
article and is full of surprises there
are a lot of white mountains some more
white mountains and these white
mountains which host one of the world's
biggest satellite ground stations
our modern infrastructure relies on the
messages sent from here but if you need
a break from nerding out the real action
takes place in the town of Longyearbyen
which was clearly named after a very
lonely coal miner who'd had enough his
dumb luck would have it I was in town
during the islands Blues Festival an
annual event that brings in serious
musicians and serves as one last drunken
hurrah before months of Darkness setting
so I got drunk and hurrah then I got a
truly horrible hangover I had a rough
night at the Blues Festival today I will
feel better by going dog sledding and
the you got the gun for the Polar Bear
situation
[Music]
[ __ ] like the private jet but like
referred away from getting around squall
line
[Music]
as the trip neared its end we went to
spell bards bizarrely amazing fine
dining establishment to celebrate things
were going fine for a while
fancy food fancy booze and then the
theme of our journey got very real it
turns out that about 4000 miles away in
Sonoma California
Nats house had been destroyed by the
fires raging through the state it's like
somebody opposes that Island Twitter he
had the gross modern experience of
seeing the remains of his house and up
on social media so there we were with
parts of California burning in Silicon
Valley going through rolling blackouts
the epicenter of Technology feeling very
fragile the mid signs that the world is
not quite right in that moment the idea
of a remote code cave made all too much
sense
[Music]
you
you